feel like the younger generation is
definitely a lot more conservative than
they were when I was 20 years old
definitely why do you think that though
uh I uh the pendulum swing is getting
quicker and quicker and quicker until
maybe it slowly just all a straight
Direction forward that's just complete
chaos I mean because you know when I was
in
middle school or whatever it was
definitely a conservatives that were
trying to stop art rap music and video
games and whatnot and
um then as I was in my mid to late 20s
it became like the woke leftists and
then seeing younger people it's just
pushing back against whatever the powers
are at the time that's what creates
conservative conservatism and then
leftism in the first place it's like
it's like the pen you said the pendulum
swing yeah so yeah the the millennial
generation is really annoying and they
don't want you to have fun and they
don't want you to laugh so then you get
people who are gen Z and younger being
like dude you're lame leave me alone
yeah I remember they were trying to ban
video games they were trying to ban
Grand Theft Auto they were trying to ban
music they're trying to ban artistic
expression and they were like these guys
are lame these guys suck but it really
makes you wonder about how you know
Society changes so quickly especially on
party lines and you kind of Wonder is is
it me who who changed or did did
something else change when I was in high
school I really loved George Carlin as
yeah probably most people in high school
do and then when I got to be about 22 I
found out that George Carlin had somehow
become a problematic comedian because he
was saying he was defending the idea
that you can make rape jokes for
instance and oh yeah Mouse raping a deer
yeah it was a Porky Pig and Elmer Fudd
and and I was like no I think yeah it's
like he should be able to make that joke
and the the Facebook uh attacks on I was
like whoa okay things have definitely
shifted without me really even seeing
what happened here how old are you uh
32. oh okay so so with your YouTube
channel now do you does your viewership
skew her younger
uh it seems like it's it's kind of Aging
with me like most people earlier on I
had a younger viewership but they're
probably all same age as you getting
older no like 20 ish now like the
majority of them growing up I kind of I
kind of think so I mean we saw the
polling from Hugh that showed gen Z is
slightly more conservative than than
Millennials but they're still very
similar in their political views and
that may just be because I think you
know I think we're all Millennials here
and we're all not necessarily
conservatives oh Lydia's conservative I
am but we're like we're called according
to the mainstream left conservative
simply because we are not in a cult in
their cult so maybe that's why a lot of
people who are who are gen Z think they
might be on the left and say that and
then they also a lot of them might think
they're conservative because most of
them are probably middle of the road
moderate and just don't believe in the
weird cult BS yeah so you know how CNN
thinks that they're the resistance I
think that gen Z is looking at that and
they're like a bunch of Boomers you're
not actually the resistance this is the
resistance is being concerned narrative
and thinking straight and maybe wearing
a collared shirt call me crazy imagine
wanting to be like Jim Acosta I'm
thinking you're the resistance yeah it's
like dude couldn't be me yeah we like
you know
we talk a lot about culture jamming and
stuff we created a an email account for
our rooster Roberto Jr you can email
them with questions Roberto Jr
timcast.com does he answer yeah the
portrait behind you no that's not that's
someone else's chicken that was a
painting I just saw and I had to get it
because it's a chicken you have to
replace it now yeah well uh you know
when we get a painting of Roberto Jr
we'll put it up uh tragically Roberto
Jr's mom died Katarina and we're
concerned there may be uh it was cancer
but there's a fear that it could
actually be there's a disease among
chickens that causes tumors so hopefully
that's not the case but you know you
know anyway what were we talking about
before you get an email for this rooster
oh right right I leave for one week yeah
we did and my point is just that like we
just kind of do weird stuff because it's
funny
and the stodgy CNN types and woke types
just are not fun it's it's just how can
you possibly have fun when you're
walking on eggshells all day I have we
have people come here and they're
hanging out and they'll say something
like oh I was making I was gonna make a
joke but I don't know can I say that and
I'm just like bro you can literally say
whatever you want like I don't I'm not
gonna
just don't you know I don't know I feel
that way more about when I'm hanging out
with uh Millennials than I do with Gen Z
really yeah I I like you can say
whatever you want I feel like like I
don't have to necessarily hold back as
much because I know gen Z still has a
like they have a sense of humor they
kind of were bred into they they do not
like Millennials and how lame and uh
sticklers dodgy yes dodgy that they are
but like Millennials it's like I'm not
saying anything unless I know unless I
hear them say it first oh no no right
right so I thought you meant that you
feel more comfortable speaking freely
with Millennials oh yeah no yeah right
oh yeah no wait I mean like yeah I think
they're just watching us uh have these
conflicts and they're like what are they
doing they're like watching us like a
theatrical kind of state right yeah
we're in our own world people are doing
and they almost are just witnessing it
like and they they come off as more you
know gathered emotionally because they
don't want to play that game that's like
what the um old people are doing right
I'm not like in those Millennials I'm
hip you know I like uh Billy eilish you
know I'm the bad guy you know what I'm
talking about gen Z they don't like take
the bait like Millennials do like we are
so over corrected yeah
um that we we just demoed some behavior
and they're not impressed with that
either so they got to see how you know
reactive we are well I don't I don't
know I don't I don't know if we fall
into that that camp like we here
obviously Millennials as like a large
group are just genuinely bad in a lot of
ways I think and um you know I think I'm
seeing more from gen Z that they're
funnier they're more chill you know
Millennials just kind of uh created the
culture that that gen Z is just
repelling and it really is like that
it's just it's like look at these lame
people like they don't know how to have
fun all they know how to do is uh
destroy things rather than yeah and
obviously there's exceptions but
yeah what do you think you think the
most Millennials are just just really
awful
um I do I think Millennials Millennials
you know it's it's a it's a terrible
generation Jen Jen I like Gen X I love
Jenna Gen X are relatively chill but
some of them are pretty bad like every
generation that's bad people it's not
it's not about like how old you are but
there's like actually I think boomers
are actually really great I think
Boomers have done some things that are
really bad uh acquiescing uh or giving
into and capitulating to is probably a
better word the woke nonsense for
Millennials gen xers kind of get lost in
between but Boomers gave us uh the Next
Generation you know Star Trek my problem
with Boomers is they're supposed to be
these wise sages that are guiding us
it's like we're in this information age
and there's all this information but
there's no wisdom it's like they're
supposed to be the ones coming and we're
supposed to have you know some sort of
like roam these sages to look up to and
we have none of that like there are
there isn't any we're so we are just a
generation that's out here floating we
got Jimmy Buffett
[Laughter]
Margaritaville yeah yeah that's true
yeah George Carlin what generation was
he was he was he silent generation oh he
was not a boomer no no he wasn't a
boomer no way he was kind of a boomer no
the thing about the Boomers though is
that they were their brains were riddled
with [ __ ] uh LSD lead and LSD yeah
break dust yeah brake pad dust yeah
George Carlin was part of the silent
generation 37. no there was a huge
impact when it came to uh lead the that
they put in the gasoline that lowered
the overall IQ levels very dramatically
there's still a lot of lead in a lot of
soils so you guys should always check
yours
is it difficult
what kind of soil what was your favorite
soil oh yeah oh uh you know any anything
with uh don't eat soil don't eat soil
actually I did I did read about a guy
who ate soil like he would get he would
eat it because it's just like organic
matter I guess but it's not a disease
mineral deficiency or something people
compelled to do that I noticed that
whenever we took the lead out of the
paint that's when they fluoridated the
water yes
the fluoride was what like 1900s like
early 1900s and the lead and the pain in
my hometown my earliest memory of NPR
was being in the back seat of my
friend's car and hearing them trying to
get um people in my hometown of Wichita
Kansas to vote to Florida the water and
they had this big you know divide two
propaganda did you hear about how they
want to put lithium in the water now
yeah yeah keep everybody from being
depressed yeah make them dull Vox wrote
that perhaps we should medicate everyone
well you know what that means that means
that they're going to come out with some
study that says of how much lithium is
already in the water from like you know
waste or people flushing them yeah
there's already a ton of prescriptions
yeah the micro Plastics and stuff that's
framing Yeah Tim you just said don't eat
the don't eat the the grass or the
ground don't drink the tap water well
you're more importantly than anything
else so what Vox did was they said in
areas that have higher deposits of
lithium in their groundwater suicide
rates are lower it's true so we should
put lithium in the water because it
makes people yeah I guess that's
breaking the world yeah if the
government if the government really
cared they would put magnesium in there
and solve a lot of medical problems at
the same time but they're not doing that
for a very responsible they're putting
byproducts of chemical waste inside of
our drinking water in order to poison
and dumb us down I think that that's
that people say that's a conspiracy I
think that's a legitimate reason
conspiracy is intent yeah what we know
what we know is they do put fluid in
water right we know that fluoride
ingested over a long period of time
lowers IQ like there's a bunch of
studies about that we know that it can
cause high amounts of fluoride can cause
Dental fluorosis so those neurotoxins
these are people who have the spotty
brittle teeth and so it's bad the
question is if the issue is that
drinking what do they say fluoride makes
your teeth better if you're older I
heard that was the argument so they
decided that we should ingest it that's
why I shower with it because yeah I mean
like you know I don't I don't know
there's different fluorides there's
there's one that of course is a chemical
byproduct and another one that is
actually natural so there's a big
difference between the two and when the
government puts it in your drink of
water they're not taking the natural uh
fluoride they're talking about the
chemical byproduct that's why Mercy
question is intent are they doing it to
make you dumb is the conspiracy theory
the fact that they are doing it is a
fact well yeah they they knew it when
they it's so toxic of a substance as
it's in these big you know these big uh
Vats that they have to not even touch it
in these hazmat suits to handle the
fluoride that they put in our drinking
water on purpose yeah most rat poison is
is fluoride you know and this is why
they have a lot of warning labels
especially on toothpaste saying if your
child ingests this you automatically
have to go through poison control
because of the fluoride I thought it was
strange they left fluoride up to any
type of democratic process at all
because they just make all kinds of
decisions and they don't ask us they're
not you know why would they filling Us
in they just they want those those
effects look at what they've done to the
diet and like the the diminished
fertility and all these things that they
that they have done they didn't
democratize us asking for those things I
feel like in 50 years people are gonna
go to like an antique store and they're
gonna be like whoa you have plastic
bottles of Coke that's crazy and they're
gonna crack open their glass bottle and
yeah don't trust any of that and even
with with the fluoride I heard another
one that it costs money to get rid of uh
chemical waste and so if you can find a
utility for it and figure out a way to
sell it uh rather than having to pay
costs to
get rid of it I love that idea there's
like a factory producing Florida as a
byproduct yeah and then yeah and then
you have to say well either we pay a
fine to dispose of this or we figure out
how to sell it and by saying well this
is good for teeth and then you work
there's like an intermingling conspiracy
with or just give it to the government
for free yeah just imagine there's like
a factory producing a bunch of like
byproduct fluoride and they go to the
local town and they go listen here buddy
you're gonna make everyone's teeth
better just take a toxic waste and dump
it right in the water supply and then
you got to pay us and the guys like that
sounds like a good idea right I don't
know that's that's the one that I I
don't know if that's if I don't that's
that's I don't know I don't know if that
that's actually how it plays out we
don't even got to get the conspiracy
here's what I can tell you fluoride is
bad for you there's a bunch of studies
there was one it was like 10 years ago
it was an aggregate of a bunch of
studies saying that like IQ is lowered
by ingesting fluoride yeah it's a
neurotoxin I was hanging out with uh I
was hanging out with my friend this is
like 15 years ago
his sister had a kid and so I walked to
the kitchen and I see Nursery Water have
you ever seen Nursery Water oh yeah and
it says big letters with added fluoride
and then I just asked I was like why are
you giving your baby fluoride and
they're like she goes it's it's Nursery
waters for babies and then I was like
they put fluoride in the baby's water
and she goes they need Florida and I was
like no they don't and I I just Googled
fluoride for babies and there was like
government websites saying like do not
do this and I showed her and she was
like but why are they selling it and I
was like because people pay for it I
don't know like the government outright
said not to give it to your babies yeah
it's like whatever man and Floyd
predominantly is a byproduct of the
fertilizer industry so that's nice
that's something well I trust the
fertilizer
big big good people in there yeah big
fertilizer Keeps Us Alive guys that's
true I mean they do technically right
they do as big fertilizer is Russia by
the way but you know that's that's the
difference big fertilizer turns us into
the fertilizer a lot faster yeah yeah do
you think we're gonna get to that point
where they recycle human waste like they
like you you die and then they throw you
into them like you guys ever see water
world
yeah yeah yeah so like in you know Water
World's about it's the The World Isn't
that Costner yeah Costner and then
there's like a floating city and what
they do is when people die they put them
into like this pit of goop where it
dissolves your body and they reuse your
organic matter because they don't want
to die you know I don't think I think
they're gonna
just recall Bill Gates drinking the
water that was what toilet water poop
water poop water I figured Bill Gates
Bill Gates and I'm gonna drink human
feces and he's trying to get other
people to do this as well that was
definitely the uh fraternal Illuminati
type of thing
he had to do that publicly like I love
drinking poop it's hazing yeah was that
before or after
um if you want to join the Illuminati
you have to drink human feces on
television I'll do it done or we release
the tape yeah
before after his exposure of being on
Epstein like visiting Epstein's uh place
it was after right um it was during I
think because he was he was with uh he
was friends with Epstein for a very long
time some people even speculate all the
way up until the 90s uh that they were
close together but they were such close
friends that his own wife says that she
divorced him because he wouldn't stop
hanging out with him whoa
I think it's implications as to why
Melinda would have to split from that
because like yeah I know what you're up
to yeah my favorite was when Bill Gates
was asked about Epstein and he goes well
he's dead now so yeah right what does it
matter yeah
he's dead now man that was like crazy
cold but but it wasn't no it wasn't so
cold it was that like it he had this
like don't mess with me it was like it
was like the same way the way he said it
was like he was happy yeah yeah it was
flippant kind of you could see like like
he was getting frustrated I was being
asked about it you you had that it has
that painting uh Epstein had the
painting of George W bush playing with
paper airplanes knocking over two Jenga
Towers oh yeah I wonder what that
painting meant huh yeah
like what what is what is George W bush
with paper airplanes knocking over Jenga
Towers had to do with anything so weird
it's really strange somebody pointed out
something new about that rather recently
turned around because that wouldn't be
the side of the desk like it was huh a
strange place in Ireland and he took
down one of the towers one of the towers
was down as he was playing with
airplanes oh the paper airplanes oh yeah
the implications are right there in the
painting George W bush used airplanes to
knock down the towers okay okay yeah
then there was paper airplanes yeah yeah
so I'm gonna pull up the photo now oh we
should probably pull up it's a very it's
a very thought-provoking photo as well
as the Bill Clinton Monica Lewinsky
dress one was also very uh interesting
to see I love how Friday just turns into
Epstein yeah I did it I did it he
finally did it I just want to know who
painted those pictures I want to know
more no there's a woman who painted them
and she doesn't know how she got them
yeah this is an interesting point the
desk is turned around the chairs behind
it but the desk is facing the wrong way
that's weird
and Bush cue the image and Bush in this
painting Knocked Down The Two Towers so
you're saying that George W bush yes
used planes to knock down the towers in
this painting in this painting in this
painting exactly yeah wow how symbolic
that's crazy so uh I was rating the
woman who painted it she painted this
and the Bill Gates in the blue dress no
no the Bill Clinton I'm sorry I'm sorry
the Bill Clinton and the Monica Lewinsky
dress that was the scandal of him of him
excreting his man juices on okay okay so
anyway thank you family friendly show I
read I read the same person painted both
and just sold them and did not know that
Epstein was the one who ended up buying
them what
though I don't know it's kind of to me
whatever you want like okay like all
jokes aside obviously we understand that
the artist was making a point about 9 11
and George W bush but I don't think you
know what happens is Epstein has this
and everyone's like oh what does it mean
was it no no hold on it just means that
someone painted this to express an idea
it doesn't mean the artist believed
which had anything to do with it it's
just kind of like a funny circumstance
you know a lot of people who believe a
lot of things they painted a picture
about it Jeff Epstein ended up buying it
believe whatever you want to believe
well we don't know you know it's
important not to jump to speculations
but at the end of the day we don't know
it's why did Epstein like it so much to
spend his own money on acquiring that
idea it's the recognition
I'd have bought both of these these
paintings yeah that's they're they're
fine they're good paintings he probably
had a lot of other uh they're very
controversial they're very in your face
when especially when it comes to you
know just questioning narratives and
embarrassing people in power so you know
there's a lot of intent that you could
speculate just by these skills alone but
just like the art it's up to
interpretation if I saw the painting of
George W bush at a gallery I'd buy it if
I saw the Bill Clinton however I don't
know you know if someone was like oh do
you know that represents I might be like
oh okay but the the bush one I'd
actually put up yes because I think it's
funny Would you rename it Patriot Act
yeah
that's the plan what's the name of it
what's the name of that piece I don't
know Google it you got a computer
you know I I just
uh there are things we don't know about
what they were doing and it's sad that
we only scratched the surface yeah you
know because I'd love to actually know
what was going on we only know one
percent of what was happening meanwhile
there's 99 of what we don't know
happening behind the scenes that
probably would blow our minds away if we
truly did understand what was happening
behind the seats of power I was thinking
about this you guys familiar with
fermi's paradox
yeah yeah everybody yeah
the general idea is if the universe is
so vast and expansive and large there
must be aliens and if so why have they
not contacted us or why haven't we
discovered them and then there's a bunch
of hypotheses proposed as to why humans
have never interacted with aliens and
there's a lot of them were like the
great Zoo hypothesis is that Earth is a
zoo for aliens they're just observing us
and then I thought about that and I was
like why don't we go a little further
what about like the great cockfighting
hypothesis that aliens don't just watch
us as a zoo they watch us to go to war
for fun and bet on who wins because I'm
like watching all this war stuff and
there's like the conspiracy theory about
aliens stopping nuclear weapons well
yeah like if you were watching like
roosters fight one of them pulled a gun
you'd be like whoa whoa come on like too
much too much
but maybe that's it maybe we're one big
cockfighting ring for aliens to watch
while everyone knows you don't bring a
gun to a cockfight but I never
understood why the aliens were trying to
bring peace to the Earth what do they
have invested I know from science
fiction you stop uh nuclear weapons
because there's radiation that leaves
the Earth and actually destroys the
potential developing life on other
planets so if they were trying to raid
life on different planets and different
universes it travels forever well that's
the theory too specifically when it
comes to Mars that Mars was a former
planet that inhibited human beings that
was inhibited what do you mean that had
human beings
inhibited and had inhibited potato you
know what I'm saying
because I thought you were saying that
something about Mars was inhibiting
growth of life now it is uh technically
but they're also finding the same
chemical only found in nuclear
explosions on Mars I forgot the exact
name of this chemical but uh yes
um it's it's a crazy Theory out there I
I I'm only scratching the surface at it
but but the same chemical that they only
found in Hiroshima Nagasaki in it
nuclear tests they found specifically
this rare chemical nuclear nuclear
nuclear nuclear uh they found those
specific that specific same element only
on the surface of Mars from from what
I've heard and seen also I just want to
also correct one of my other mistakes I
said Google sorry I I use brave brave
browser here's the evidence apologies
for uh making another mistake here
evidence for a large anomalous nuclear
explosions in Mars's past from hou Dot
from usra.edu
Mars Isotopes Baseline Viking Lander
Mars meteorites I don't know I just
Googled this is what came up it's a
school it's got a bunch of fancy things
in it therefore it means it's right I
believe it I believe it hydrogen bombs
are boosted by fission of uranium or
thorium casing around 50 of yield is
fission this creates Xenon Isotopes is
that what they're referring to Xenon I'm
looking it up right now just to make
sure I have everything here but I go
deep down the rabbit hole and this is
like a rabbit hole that I went down a
few years ago so I'm now just refreshing
my memory of like oh crap you know
there's probably human beings on Mars
let's look at the evidence suggesting
this or even just like fragile life on a
distant planet could easily be wiped out
by small amounts of radiation that's
what Arthur C Clarke uh wrote about a
lot but also he's conspired to be a uh
Pito himself so we should nuke Mars oh
we should yeah every every planet with
nuke should fire every single nuke just
right at the North Pole of Mars why for
fun oh
see what happens it is another planet
yeah I don't care yeah we got this new
what do we got we got some uh 50 Megaton
icbms it was far off a couple of those
just tests just all of them all of them
no you don't gotta test them if they if
they bunk out whatever who cares is that
your plan to disarm the world of nuclear
weapons I think that's no no no no no no
no no we should be making exponentially
more so we can have a consistent stream
of just just bombing the crap out of
Mars Just Just massive explosions just
you know and then we watch yeah well
could we get a lot but we watch and
we're like and we sell it on
pay-per-view could we bomb it so much
that it turned into comets then smashed
into you know the Fox News has an
article about this and so does the epoch
times saying uh this is the title here
Tim evidence of ancient nuclear
explosion on Mars says scientist
um and this is from an article in 2015
and that's probably when I read it yeah
and this is this is now coming to the
surface of like hey there's a lot more
to this than I actually thought why why
aren't you using Brave bro what are you
talking about oh my gosh Epoch times
evidence of ancient nuclear explosion on
Mars
says scientist continue reading for free
okay or I can just press the escape
button yeah
evidence of ancient nuclear explosion on
Mars nuclear reactions on Mars Earth had
to be natural this is from 2015. yeah
Xenon particles producing nuclear
reactions surface of the red planet the
likely the result of two large anomalous
nuclear explosions on Mars in the past
argues propulsion scientist Dr John
Brandenburg in a 2014 paper titled
evidence of a massive thermonuclear
explosion on a Mars in the past on Mars
in the past oh well
when passed like how long ago yeah we
don't know is it possible that it's just
one of those things that's natural like
I know some planets have reigns of
diamonds is it possible that someone
fired a nuke at Russia and just didn't
say anything and then studied it and
then when we sent the Rovers they found
it went oh it was a bomb it's like or or
like you were saying is it possible that
something that happened here with a
nuclear test went out and after what
does it take like 20 minutes for light
to reach Mars or whatever yeah then it
impacted something there yeah I don't
know when the when was the study but I
mean how long ago was the Tsar bomb
yeah 50 Megaton Gravity Bomb probably
leaves some some traces of residue on
Mars you know I was thinking
I was just thinking crazy stuff and I
was like
I was thinking about radio waves how we
don't see anything coming out of our
phone but we know it's there because we
can see the cause and effect and then
I'm just like what if in other
dimensions the radio waves have a
tremendously detrimental impact
unlike other dimensions that other
beings live in and so just imagine if
all of a sudden you started feeling like
you were being shoved and like things
were slamming into your face and then in
like some other dimension like a higher
or lower Dimension or something
somebody's just like playing a game on
their phone and texting and then they
use
things that interact with our Dimension
and theirs you know what I mean yeah if
that was the case I guess from just a
creative writing standpoint then we
would already be feeling those and come
up with our own understanding of why
that's happening who knows like
temperature or wind or something like
that I mean I suppose it would have to
be anomalous Oh No Maybe not maybe it
would have to be a pat there would be a
consistent pattern of of some kind of
you know reaction because they
constantly do it so like each and every
one of us has a phone that's working all
the time so whatever in this other
dimension is being impacted by that
would just see it happening and assume
it's a natural phenomenon
unless it started up randomly and like
hey all of a sudden around 2007 this
thing started happening you know what I
love about this is that none of us are
on any kind of alternative substances
right now all Alternatives yeah you know
what I mean no I'm what's what's what's
what's the opposite of alternative then
um Pro turn I have no idea that's not a
thing right normative normative I'm
drinking seed oil golden milk turmeric
in the seed oils but it has two work in
it it cures what ails you and the seed
oils yeah yeah right yeah but turmeric's
anti-inflammatory right so it balances
out you got the seed oils that cause
inflammation and then turmeric that that
levels that inflammation you know it's
like a speed it's like a speed ball
right where did you hear about the seed
oil stuff
um a whole bunch of different places
you eat murder Burgers sometimes too
murder Burgers no I don't okay I don't
know probably I'm just guessing about me
no way listen you know you can't always
be perfect but you can always strive for
Perfection you can always this guy he's
like don't drink that coffee table it's
got seed oils and I was like bro like
two weeks ago you went to McDonald's I
don't know what you're talking about I
have no idea you might have mixed me up
with somebody else you went to
Chick-fil-A like last week I don't know
what you're saying that you get you get
chicken chicken nuggets all the time
with all your little high fructose corn
syrup juice you get the sauce how many
sauces do you get like seven no no you
get like 20 sauces and then
you're like hold on I'm talking down
fructose juices there I think everyone
agrees that for every single piece of
chicken you need a full packet of
barbecue sauce do you see what I'm
talking see what I'm dealing with here
the lunacy and I get criticized for
eating Chick-fil-A once I'm not the one
who's screaming about seed oils we could
always try to help hold each other
accountable at least somehow that's fair
so I'm not the one who like I pull I get
this coffee lucky Jack cold brew golden
tumeric whatever you're like look how
healthy it is I'm like read the
ingredients right now it doesn't say
seeds yes it does yeah
by this time next year you'll be soaking
sunflower oils it's coming for you
organic cane sugar
but it's got It's got turmeric in it
it's got black pepper in it that
surprised me really this is black pepper
makes turmeric work with other black
pepper a term I can't it's like the
action yeah for real yeah that's why a
lot of turmeric supplements have black
pepper in it black pepper is in all
those um like juice shots and stuff okay
Ginger and all that and cayenne and
lemon and yeah that's why all the it's
in there pepper and pepperon has some
kind of uh it's some kind of you know
feature I don't know what you call that
a feature but a characteristic of it
that makes stuff boost your metabolism
or something you guys know how like the
chickens are just like doing whatever
and have no idea what's going on up here
they got their chicken City with their
chicken Society their chicken food and
chicken friends you know what if that's
just us
right that's us we we we talk about
things like turmeric and we're all
really serious about it and it's about
as serious as a rooster going that's how
government views us is how you view your
chickens exactly they're like look how
they don't know anything this is silly
exactly look at their like happy and
content with voting obviously we do
whatever we want anyway and they think
they have something to do with it
democratically okay but what if what if
that's like what if they're aliens you
know and they just look at us like a
chicken coop and we're just dumb okay so
exhibit one is probably Nancy Pelosi I'm
just saying there's a few people in
there that for sure she probably has two
of them no I would say she probably has
two aliens inside of her don't do that
are working together
no that's a good point yeah two big
aliens right here two big aliens right
like is there is there like a protrusion
or something that you can see on her
body where the aliens may be hiding they
have to be on the upper torso since that
makes the most logical sense okay that
these two protruding big Goblin aliens
are located right I feel like jellyfish
aliens yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah very
very strictly very very soft to the
touch
but yeah in some instances as well but
but also extremely flexible and and
moves around thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there